hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds if you're
wondering why there's no music playing
at all in a UFO just went by it's
because I was sitting here on the main
menu for too long and it accidentally
went wrong for me
but this time I'm going to begin this
adventure and I'm going to survive
because I know what I need to get I have
to get the radio I have to that's
literally the only equipment that I need
and the radio is oddly enough so anyway
we're gonna get this soap everybody
ready
I don't know the radio is but I don't I
don't I don't frankly I don't care we're
just gonna get this get it get it get a
get a get a get a get a get a get a lock
whatever fine whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever just dump it in dump
it in dump it in we don't have time okay
get the soup get a little Timmy here
okay we're doing fine we're doing fine
suitcase no room okay more soup more
soup more soup more soup more soup more
soup more soup more soup okay get that
okay keep going
all right in the kitchen where we got
plenty of bottles of water actually this
is the bathroom but that's there's the
radio yes yes okay so the radio does
move and I'm not just a stupid I mean
I'm pretty stupid but it's okay I need
the rest of my family I guess they're
pretty important probably can soup can
soup to the shelter to the shelter come
on come on okay get the wife okay get
the wife get the wife this flashlight is
fine we got the radio we got that I'm
gonna get this can of soup okay go go go
go go go go okay to the shelter to the
shelter grab this grab this grab back
let's go oh that was right down to the
wire guys but we had a lot of good stuff
there so this is a good start to us I
don't know what was in that suitcase but
it was what I grabbed just because I
grabbed it I didn't every little time to
go wow I got a lot of achievements for
that one Oh looks like we've got four
cans of soup five bottles water medkit
radio flashlight suitcase first we get
alright all of us and there's a med kit
in the suitcase
can't remember breathing those lies Oh
No oh okay so that was actually just an
extra that we had let's see and oh we
got a game board with probably not all
the pieces in place because why would
that happen
well rushing into an emergency and we
only have 60 seconds before total
nuclear annihilation we're not really
gonna do much in the way of get we have
five and five we have five and five we
have five and five oh we have five and
five we got five soups and five water's
we're gonna do so good here because I'm
going to be the strictest dad that ever
was strict in the world the lore as long
as me no matter what well I'm going to
be rose that was not a flashlight I
don't know what's got let's just leave
all those questions be for now I wasn't
asking any questions but if I'm already
going crazy day too into this trip it's
not gonna go well for us okay Mary
Jane's worried Timmy Knight is doing
fine
Dolores is doing well and the morning
has been calm enough for Ted
no one needs anything okay so we're good
we felt like something was staring oh no
not this again
no my food no I should've grabbed the ax
right there oh no it takes a whole can
we don't have anything oh no oh no oh no
oh no actually I don't think I need to
give it to him until the next day and
that's when they really need it oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh Mary Jane you're
the champion go out there do good bring
the suitcase I guess because maybe you
can haul some stuff back in it I don't
know oh no oh no oh the suitcase lets
you bring more other equipment oh I
didn't know that okay dammit dammit
dammit
mary-jane went outside terrible shape we
need to give water yeah I know we all
need water will get water water water
water
oh man it's very difficult to prepare
for the unforeseen just like I didn't
know that there would be a giant hungry
rat which is gonna turn into a giant
hungry fluffy bunny down the road and
steal all the food damn it
Timmy is good Dolores is fine that's
fine I'm so sad I'm so sad I'm so sad
and mad and upset but we're gonna
survive through this because I will not
let this stop us sorry I hit the
microphone it doesn't matter it's okay
still better to be out here we have what
they say let's see no everything's good
everything good everyone's fine okay so
get the radio going and everything will
be okay why am I out of breath I don't
know mind you I'm very into this at the
moment
well how fortunate we took the radio we
can probably listen to some music they
still play music I don't know maybe okay
all right so everyone's still fine
you're not gonna get food yet ooh the
other day we heard a quiet knock on our
door but when we opened it we only found
a suitcase on the doorstep and no one
around it isn't signed but it sure looks
like it was meant for us should we check
what's inside of course what could be
wrong in the suitcase it's probably not
gonna be bad
oh and Mary Jane is back and very sick
is the sweet sweet prospect of
government aid hey we're no commies but
centrally-planned helped during the
apocalypse is something we're really
looking forward to our expedition exited
the shelter right before the airdrop
started falling out of the sky one of
the food drops broke midair and now it's
raining oh oh yes we've got we force one
of the boxes open
oh man that's so cool oh that's so cool
oh that's so cool okay we got perfect
timing for all this is so great right
before the airdrop oh that's so nice
okay everyone gets everything everyone
gets a share of everything because we're
doing so wonderfully today and me even
Mary Jane is going to be better
oh all right who's gonna all right we
didn't expect to get a phone call so
soon after the atomic bomb drop you here
we are would clearly your phone ringing
outside it must be the public phone
booth on the other side Street someone
answer it yeah Timmy go up come on go
Timmy get the phone Timmy Timmy come get
the phone Timmy Timmy Timmy Timmy okay
Jimmy's back Jimmy's fine who was it
when we answered the phone we could
clear in here okay it's a gas but relief
everyone's very happy about that unless
someone's gonna come over here and steal
all from us okay so everyone is fine we
are doing so good we are doing so
wonderfully okay whoa this is good oh
this is good oh this is so good okay
okay well is that gentle snoring is that
supposed to happen I have no idea okay
played hide and seek the longest run we
were able to play last up around 10
seconds that was only because the lights
went out for a moment
okay so marriage ends quite hungry
Timmy's hungry okay so Mary Jane and
Timmy are very hungry I'll just give him
some soup since we have someone to spare
and then Ted is going outside he's gonna
take the suitcase again because for some
reason that lets him take just a whole
bunch of stuff so we have a gas mask
he's gonna take that we're gonna leave
the gun in here kind of important I
don't know why he would need to take a
whole bunch of other stuff oh well
whatever we're gonna do this Ted you're
the man I believe in you you're the man
with the plan go get him big boy go get
him buddy he's gonna be fine I trust him
I trust him a hundred percent he's cool
he's cool in my book okay everyone asked
to drink sometimes including mary-jane
is there any water left okay Mary needs
water tim is hungry and Timmy needs
water
Virginia water Virginia is water Tim
needs food and water water is for
Dolores Timmy needs food water that was
right right yeah okay got it as long as
we have food and water we can stay
locked in but we'll eventually have to
leave it would be good to head straight
for safety okay
talk on the radio we're gonna get it
we're gonna do this one I have a good
feeling about this as the dad who has
now left the responsibility of caring
for his family it's gonna be fine
we knew what the government hasn't
followed okay Timmy should eat Timmy
just ate didn't Timmy just eat I'm
pretty sure Timmy just ate okay
difficult to keep track of time actually
Timmy doesn't need to eat yet Timmy
should eat something he's not ready to
eat yet okay difficult to keep track of
time let's use the board oh whoa whoa I
imagine that it's gonna last many many
days down here okay taking Culliver in
the shelter okay okay
everyone's fine everyone's fine you know
it's been a while we're gonna look in
listen in listen duck cover grab our
butts kiss him goodbye
Ted's back Ted looks good that looks
a-okay it looked great actually
we were able to get a weak signal and
tap into government's emergency
announcement surface and guess what the
filed outside is mostly gone okay good
that's good we gonna call when the world
is on fire the fire department we were
thrilled to find the place still running
firefighters we've located we did some
of their oh my god nice all right
Nestle painted green skull symbol oh wow
Oh Oh firefighters redecorated the place
and redid their outfits most of the
walls were messily painted in black and
red and the firemen helmets now have a
grim skull symbol on them we never
thought our local firefighters had such
artistic souls alternative that doesn't
sound good
is there a roving band of firefighters
ready to murder anyone that goes out on
the service doesn't sound good
near the garage we found a few
firefighters shooing off some giant
mutated cockroaches with a fire hose we
joined in on the fun I managed to fill
bottles of water in the Brocker bosses
okay good although initially friendly
the firefighters became a bit anxious
after a while the hand is this can of
bug spray and asked us not to tell
anyone about what we saw here we're not
sure why maybe they're too humble and
don't want people to come and shower
them with gifts damn it we really like
that suitcase well it's gone now okay
all right Mary Jane needs something to
drink Timmy needs food and water
Delores needs food and water Ted is
really tired that sounds like we don't
need everyone to have something just yet
we're gonna wait another day we're gonna
wait another day all right we're gonna
prep for actually no actually I'm gonna
give that's right I'm gonna give Timmy
food and water because he's about to go
out tomorrow cuz Timmy's a strong boy
Timmy can do it Timmy can go with to the
wasteland he's gonna be fine we were
sure we'd look through our supplies
carefully but mary-jane spotted
something of all of us missed a seed a
plant seed we should plant it to see
what happens but we we need a bottle of
water for that should we do it we just
so happened to have a surplus of water
so I may okay with trying this bottle of
water to plant the seed even though
there's probably not gonna do any good
for us because what the hell would it
bother yeah that didn't work out did it
see here goes nothing soil sees water
we'll see what happens in a few days
time let's just hope those seeds don't
turn into some useless foul flower mary
jane seems optimistic okay Mary Jane
needs water really badly
Dolores needs food Ted needs food okay
food we've been preparing for this
expedition Timmy's gonna go outside
Timmy's got it I believe in Timmy
Timmy's a good boy Timmy can do it and
there's giant mutant cockroaches out
there so I'm gonna take the bug spray
with us I don't know if that's gonna do
any good but I think that's the hint who
was trying to get to me and my inner
game sense is telling me
big giant cockroaches me bug spray even
though that probably needed it down here
because I don't need the gas mask
anymore because now it's safer to go out
there's never a good time to go out into
the radioactive wasteland but it seems
this will become a necessity in the new
world of ours we thought it would be a
good idea to make this happen sooner
rather than later and a planned trip
outside before we can make the third
steps beyond the shelter doors an
unknown creature start growling at us
from the darkest we only had moments to
decide what to do flashlight look at it
it could be a friendly dog a frenzied
dog they're not taking any of my [ __ ] we
decide to check what's coming for us
with our flashlight guess what it was a
dog the poor thing seemed tired so we
led to stay with us for the night the
next morning we opened the door to let
it out it sells in return hopefully
we'll come back later oh poor little
blob Oh hopefully it'll come back with
something okay everything is shaking
cans are jumping all over the place if
this habit happened after we drank okay
it's an earthquake need to save the
radio no matter what we're saving the
radio the gas masks I hope goes because
frankly we don't need it yes Oh No
got both of them well that's not fair
that's not fair at all god damn it okay
Mary Jane needs water Ted needs some
food all right
we found an unsigned letter today The
Strangers asked for our help apparently
there are a few survivors of great need
to supplies and we have a chance to help
them they're saying that we won't regret
it and we would make several people very
very happy oh but I'm low on soup man I
alright fine
hi I'm a nice I'm a nice guy you can get
one of the post shoutout cans of soup
the ones that really splintered oh no
now we're suddenly doing very poorly the
authors of the note turned out to be
twin siblings a brother and sister they
greeted us happily and took us to a
small tent where they started handing
out the supplies we brought to a small
group of hungry survivors between them
were people of all ages including
children the elderly and even a mime the
siblings shook our hands and proclaimed
that this is the beginning of a new
friendship they promised to contact us
again soon okay cool
weird twin siblings I wonder if that's a
reference to anything Mary Jane
no trouble dared to cross her path
didn't
any trouble okay so the one thing water
for Dolores its he get water for Dolores
food at Ted's fine play game they said
it'll be fun they said blah blah blah
blah Timmy's back Timmy
Oh Timmy you don't look so good what did
you contract out there were you just
rolling purely in mud and mud alone we
thought playing the silent game would be
a good idea we were so afraid for Timmy
but he's backed the local school house
is a big building a mile away from our
house nobody liked that place the atomic
blast didn't change that now without
windows and a few walrus remaining it
looks even more unpleasant pleasant or
not it seemed like a good spot to hunt
for supplies we got a can of soup all
right and two cans of water the PE
teacher with the World War two veteran
he kept yes new o new gas masks and okay
so that's good at one point during our
expedition we were ambushed by a pack of
mutated cockroaches we managed to scare
them away with bug spray I called it I
called it oh I knew it oh I knew it oh I
knew it I knew it
Oh Mary James fine Timmy's not feeling
so good but that's fine
oh man that needs food and water Timmy
could use food oh that's so good oh
that's so good oh yeah we don't have
anything to heal Timmy up hopefully he's
gonna feel fine after a while Mary Jane
doesn't need anything Delores doesn't
need anything oh that's so good you know
what you get some water Timmy just
because I can cuz I feel like sparing it
all right huh
plants are usually green so it shouldn't
be too worried that Mary Jane's plant is
a bit glowy it shines with a healthy
greenish color maybe that means it will
bear more fruit or vegetables or
whatever those twisted things hanging
from the plant are shall we collect them
now okay is this where everything's
gonna go horribly wrong I'm pretty sure
it's not supposed to glow green that's
probably bad
but I wasted a can of water on this so
of course I'm gonna harvest this oh that
doesn't sound good
someone looks in bad shape Cloris what
did you do let's see good call with the
plant we were able to procure the
clothes seemed to give it extra
nutritional value seemed to we're not
scientists on the matter but it's good
enough for us all right water for Mary
Jane Timmy's hungry okay water for Mary
Jane
Ted seems to be alright okay water for
Mary food for Timmy for Mary food for
dinner okay oh this is so good we got so
much stuff do we even need to go out do
we even need to go out I would send
Dolores but Mary Jane seems to be fine
Flores is tired she can't go out see
Mary Jane yeah I could send Mary Jane
out that's fine all right
he looks good all right what can she
have don't need the gas masks anymore
could do the map cuz that way she could
know where she's going that could help
her out okay that's really good all
right Mary Jane I believe in you climb
waah go with go with the go with good
luck I guess I don't know if you're
gonna be fine but it's gonna be good
enough okay
Timmy's hungry still probably cuz he's
sick Dolores needs something to eat and
water okay I'm just gonna keep giving
Timmy food because he's sick I'm hoping
he gets better soon
oh no no we're not gonna get evacuated
now damn it this is [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] this is [ __ ]
we were sure we could find the location
without a map we were wrong hopefully
we'll get lucky next time Oh No
oh we were about to take a cautious peek
outside when a furry beast jumped us
good thing our hearts were not battered
by a fat heavy hamburger diet because it
was our dog friend and not I'm even
lurking to chew our bones
he seems hungry shall we give him
something to eat yes of course we shall
because he's a good boy and we treat our
friends with respect even though we just
so happened to not have the map at the
right time oh well the dog was back to
his former self in under an hour we
don't know what they put in that soup
but man that stuff is good we decided
the dog needed the name and the right
name for us with the pancake come here
pancake let's go ah boy
bang keg stayed for a while but was gone
the next morning we couldn't bet he will
be back Timmy he's looking very pale
that's not good
Delores would really love to eat
something okay so food for Delores Oh No
if we don't do anything about Timmy
sickness but we didn't have anything
how want to do anything Timmy have some
water fluids are good when you're sick I
guess oh no a group of doctors knocked
on our door today requesting some
supplies that would be helpful for
refilling their first-aid kits we didn't
doubt that they're real for a second
they did have lab coats and everything
should we help him sure why not what's
the worst gonna happen we got plenty of
supplies no big deal
see the bottle of relatively clean
waters are closest we'll ever get to
hydrogen peroxide like a good Scouty as
Timmy
is making the best out of the situation
he even seems cheerful okay water for
Dolores okay water for everybody all
right water for everybody just because
I'm worried about Timmy it said he was
okay I don't know if he is now but it
seemed okay all right it's hard not to
worry considering the situation Timmy's
good okay Timmy's good
Timmy's good everyone's good everyone's
a-okay an uneventful day going right on
by Oh Mary Jane you here oh all you here
oh okay so she brought the map that
little trip to the surface might have
been spotted we should be more careful
with the purely place so we got one
thing of water one thing of water any
place can be interesting enough to look
for supplies garbage cans garbage
collection was supposed to be happening
around this time but the truck never
game we never thought we could say that
but we aren't complaining why do people
throw our water [ __ ] oh just one water
Mary Jane come on Mary Jane you you're
lucky I'm gonna give you food damn it
fine have some food whatever
Ted Ted's mom and dad's my man that's my
man he's gonna go out the siblings are
back the group is growing bigger with
each passing day and they pick up tired
and hungry survivors in the earth-sun
back to health however so far they only
have one tenant soon they will run out
of space for everybody right now they're
scouting the town looking for a good
spot to build a bigger camp I think it
really is by the way we're surviving a
lot longer than its cereal said we'd be
surviving
see they didn't have to ask twice these
people are very friendly in the way they
take care of others is impressive we
showed them the map and pointed out a
few bandit caps they should avoid they
were grateful and stayed for a little
chat they said they would be more than
happy if we came to visit there want
them once their camp is ready we can't
wait to see how it turns out Mary James
hungry Timmy's hungry see Timmy needs
water Delores has to drink
Ted wishes for a few drops of water okay
they can survive we need to be very
stringent about that because I don't
know I don't know if I I don't know if I
should Ted and send Ted out you know
what I gotta send that out because if we
if we just stay here we're not gonna be
doing good take the padlock because I
don't know what that's gonna do for us
if I need the padlock right soon I'm
going to be very upset but it's okay
you'll be fine everything's gonna be
fine okay Mary Jane needs food
Timmy needs water to food Delores needs
water okay food water water to be hungry
and water
we heard barking we were at the door in
a moment's notice this time we were
right it was pancake he had come back
but that wasn't willing to enter instead
he seemed very anxious to lead us
somewhere should we grab any gear before
we head out how about the gun gun sounds
good gun sounds good gun sounds real
good alright go to go to gumdrops maybe
the map I don't know
map gun I could lose the map you meenie
miney moe catch a tiger by the toe which
one should I do which one should I do
which one should I do
alright gun you look at bad shape the
old saying goes better safe than sorry
the rifle seemed to be the right choice
of gear for venturing out in the unknown
we didn't expect to run into
trigger-happy foe who started shooting
before asking questions gunshots were
enough to send pancake running we got
back to safety but he didn't show up
what is that good or bad I don't
understand what Oh Mary Jane can survive
longer
I don't know if that's good or bad
remember that time Mary Jane went out to
scavenge supplies when she got back she
had a wound on her forearm nothing
something had bitten her oh I don't have
all man the axe to chop it off that
seems a little extreme don't you think
she get bit by a radioactive spider oh
god that doesn't look good that looks
very bad
oh no Mary Jane will be fine it's not
the first time and it won't be the last
time she's sick she did looking pale the
day though keeps fanning she needs water
oh boy
water for Mary Jane oh man we are in
dire straits we gotta get yes oh yes map
no oh man I couldn't lost the map if I
went out with the map last time so this
is good okay okay okay okay we're gonna
get rescued we're gonna be fine we're
gonna get rescued and it's gonna be okay
Ted Anna Ted has been outside for far
too long and silly has not returned what
we fear he isn't coming back Ted Timmy
what huh huh huh
Timmy was very sick and there was
nothing we could have done to make it
better he understood he was and probably
decided he's better off away from such a
responsible parents he left and never
came back
oh well I can take care of them
I took a care of them but I took care or
that green puddle come from oh dear a
pipe is leaking green goo that's not
good we need to act what should we do
oh man why is this all falling apart now
stay 35 jeez jeez man Oh No
oh no I'm not sending anyone else
outside cuz I'm not leaving
no way no I'm not it's not happening
we're gonna stay in this little shelter
the loris is gonna stay down here
because the Lord's can last a long time
by herself until she needs to get
rescued why is Ted gone forever
oh damn it something blew up inside the
radio and the wretched thing caught fire
when we opened the bunker door this
morning to let some fresh radioactive
air we discovered a small suitcase note
on it should we take a look inside
absolutely we should look inside cuz
what else could go wrong
oh no damn it the gift was booby-trapped
there was nothing inside but some junk
as soon as we opened it it exploded is
anybody hurt it just exploded oh good oh
man man J needs water
they both need water and now Dolores is
hurt
how is she hurt sure Oh his legs been
blown good great great we were afraid we
wouldn't hear back again but our friends
are back the siblings are proudly
declared that their camp is ready but
they have one more thing in mind for it
at school they want to somehow educate
the children that lived there they
already appointed a few people to teach
but they're a bit short on reading
material I got nothing unfortunately I
never ever ever picked up the Survival
Guide so I'm boned on that one when
emptying our bucket in front of the
shelter we discovered the hastily drawn
map on one of the ruined walls someone
drew out a route and marked a spot the
end of it maybe their supplies hidden
there we should check Mary Jane go for
it
you got it I believe in you go on get
out there well that doesn't seem good
that she's not back Mary Jane was
supposed to be back in a few days but
it's been too long we fear something bad
has happened to her oh come on
luckily lucky fine we were afraid the
map was a trap leading a straight into
of camp full of bandits but it turned
out to be true at the end of the path we
found some supplies that might be
helpful for us Mary Jane
there was no point in you going
there was no point there was no point
the Raider camp on our Street has been
especially maddening lately they're
acting like real savages we won't stand
for that somebody should show them that
innocence survivors of the wasteland
aren't just miserable victims ok Dolores
go out in a blaze of glory you shoot him
up you bang bang boom bang oh you're
alive wow that's actually kind of
amazing
we bravely stormed into the camp
screaming insults and threats at the top
of our lungs
meaning Dolores did this by herself just
an old school mom just like how's the
best impression of a soccer mom that I
could possibly do soccer mom did no
husband and no children anymore oh
that's sad sadly there was no one there
to appreciate her courage it looks like
the Bandit when rating and left the camp
empty thinking no one would dare get
close to it anyway but not us we
fearlessly collected whatever we could
from this wise and courageously ran back
to our shelter we think it's the
ultimate proof that we're not in danger
we are the danger we are the danger ok
and apparently I can do something about
Dolores his injuries now she's gonna
survive she's gonna survive alone but
she's gonna survive damn it where the
goddamn is our rescue holy tits oh she's
not doing good I just what her sanity is
questionable oh no is that because she's
got no one it's some fruit and water
that will help you you're confident
you're survived outside we slam full
supplies like this man knocking on the
other side of the door knocking and
claiming that he's willing to offer a
lot for decent ammunition shall we trade
okay I got decent ammunition I don't
think the checkerboard is good enough
but I got decent ammunition I don't know
what good is gonna do me I already
banged it all in the band camp did I get
anything in return mm-hmm we handed the
ammunition to the stranger in the
offered oh thank you thank you very much
but Dolores isn't doing so good
Dolores isn't home right now another
radio broadcast from the military was a
huge shock for us not only did they
postpone our rescue they also ordered
all survivors to get rid of their
firearms are they nuts how are we
supposed to defend ourselves they'd
better be worth it all right whatever
fine then I guess what more could go
wrong Dolores is almost bonkers cuckoo
oh no we decided to follow the military
orders we did it with the heavy heart
but if it's the price of getting safely
all right well getting the family to
safety um you mean Dolores who's half
gone sanity is very questioned how about
nothing you get nothing how about how
about how about water how about water
you get water 45 days Oh 45 days 45 days
in the apocalypse lovely lovely time
why did Ted have to go everything seems
okay with Dolores I'm not all represent
sure about that
I'm pretty sure that's the opposite of
the truth we got a visit today from a
person with the physical mutation he
managed to grow several extra fully
operational hands he's still free of his
group with us people with other
deformities who despite the
circumstances remain friendly and
struggle to gather supplies wherever
they go
people just shoo them away and fear of
getting sick your promises that if we
gift him some supplies his group will
help us get rid of the bandits next time
they bother us okay I think I got soup
to spare why not you know what why not
why not why not day 47 he's shocked if I
make it to 50 it feels good to have some
friends in this cruel empty wasteland a
few of our supplies is a small price to
pay when it comes to the safety of our
family once again
just Dolores sitting alone in a basement
all by herself with known to keep her
company but the radiation and the sounds
of a clicking radio and the rats don't
forget the dying rats and a giant fluffy
bunny named fluffernutter someone paid
us a visit today it was an overly
cheerful red-haired woman accompanied by
a grumpy looking mercenary type who was
prolly her guard she told us she was a
traitor
and she'd eagerly trade us some things
for some things
bug spray four gas masks med kit four
bullets I only have a gas mask is that
gonna do good enough all right whatever
we're gonna try it I got nothing better
to do and I'm pretty sure Dolores is on
her way out I made it to 50 somehow
don't know how but I did it and then I'm
gonna send Dolores off into the
wasteland with nothing else but bug
spray yep
anyway what was that everybody seemed
pretty useless we already know the
radiation is dangerous in the hitting a
rat with a stick will eventually kill it
okay good job trader lady alright off
you go then you go with the Industrial
bug spray and you have a good time out
there Delores you have a good time even
though you're crazy
she's not gonna make it the end that's
the end oh that's a new screen holy crap
what the hell is bad why is the mailman
out there well this is a completely new
screen oh we found access to our house
restricted by concrete barriers and a
small platoon of heavily armed soldiers
patrolling the area around it we thought
that's our ticket out of here but they
just took everything we had and chased
stuff off end of the wasteland guess
we'll be hunter-gatherers now like in
the good old Stone Age days what huh why
did they wall off our house well that
doesn't make any sense
what we didn't get rescued was it the
point of that was at the point that they
would never rescue us in the first place
that's not how the game would end and I
had to trust like twins doing their
thing is that how it was supposed to be
what oh my goodness the government took
over our shelter Wow foon da ba that's
no good even the mailman who probably
was telling us that we were all gonna be
a-ok and we could go out and have fun
well I survived for 55 days on my own
tad is dead somewhere in the wasteland
you were driven away well that's new
thank you
driven away into where all right anyway
that's all the time I have for 60
seconds tell me what I did wrong in the
comments below
probably just didn't have enough stuff
that I was supposed to be able to do
everything that I needed to and the
expedition somehow went very awry so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching I hope to get back to this in a
new episode and do way better very soon
so thanks again and as always I will see
you
in the next video how dare they well
they're hiding something in here why are
you shaking the crowd good lordy Lou you
are massive